gotta get back
gotta get back back to the past am i
right jack because last time I did
something that we didn't save so I have
to go back to the past because I don't
know where we were what are you talking
about I'm saying
we finished later in the show than we
were
what's that oh yeah you went like I went
what killed a spider but now we didn't
save it so I got a I got to redo that or
we get in that room somehow I got to
redo all this stuff anyway so I already
saved we we discussed shooting the last
shotgun and then ditching it cuz it's
not that valuable I got this med kit I
got a residence key yeah examine that
that sounds important oh wait but I'm in
my I'm in my box you know then I got
grenade shells and that sounds like
something I don't need until later so
I'm gonna put that away or the first-aid
kit
well I feel like it's good to have at
least one med thing I would take like an
herb or something for being like really
cautious with med kits considering I
feel like I have a lot or I'm trying to
get you killed
or maybe this game I'm so good at this
game that you know I won't need it
because I will live alright here we go
that's what was that's what's happening
that's what I thought
gallery flip it around yeah look nothing
unusual gallery alright I forget exactly
where that's at but I know that this
place is a nightmare we can go there but
should we also go to the spider room and
see what was in there yeah sure I think
that sounds good
do it up all right cool let me just
remember let me collect my my bearings
here I forget which ones the gallery but
I think it's in this this area is it not
great across the street or something
okay seems reasonable don't-don't-don't
that's where you got the gallery key in
there correct so yeah this is a spider
room this is spider room yes alright so
I'm gonna go in there and see if there's
anything useful mm-hmm now I killed the
spider previously because I didn't say
it's spider is alive and you had
possibly mentioned to me perhaps just
don't kill the spider you can it's just
he's pretty easy to avoid if hear what
he's this about it the green herb right
there I mean I know but I have one cuz
we didn't talk about this should I knock
upstairs I would just I would get the
green herb now while you can
in case the spiders like near it later
but he's gonna eat me there's multiple
spiders you didn't tell me about
multiple I'm gonna tell you about a lot
of things oh my god I'm 42 or the Sharks
or the the third spider are they like
zoms where like I can just ditch them
yeah but then the third one's gonna be
out soon
there's wait a minute bandage with blood
I'm gonna take it yeah like why would I
not take it oh I'm full there's nothing
else in here that I would wreck
getting now interesting a green oil lamp
and then there's dose med kit but I
can't take it is there anything else
wine bottles lies scattered about
they's all empty it's getting crunk up
in here yeah sorry sick but the most
famous the resident evil buds and orange
oil wasn't an evil reactor yep it was
pretty bad
wait there was a spider up here there
some billiard balls just she's counting
them two three four five six interesting
bunch of nudie girls but there's a
guitar right here can you play me a tune
as soon as I do moonlight sonata on the
piano all right so it's interesting that
this is even up for debate
yeah yeah tight spot huh well you told
me I could avoid them we can it's coming
up can mouse around this this year
billiard table I don't like cat mouse
thing with giant spiders I'd rather them
just die come on look at this one you
can see his innards where is he why
isn't he coming
oh he just pounced my needy is one of
those green herbs
why are you careful no you're good
you're good you can kill him if you want
oh they're horrible you got a lot of oh
wait I don't I don't need anything else
in here
well they're not come this way okay ooh
this record player another new T girl
thank God you were here
good call Mike mm-hmm that's why I led
you over there oh no wait a minute hold
on there's something important check out
that butt so I got in a green and orange
and a red oil lamp all or not live
another Iraq of full wine bottles
they're cheap vintages I had no idea she
was such a wine connoisseur and that's
it
all right well what why would those oil
lamps be there if you didn't have to do
anything with it well you're gonna to
light them but I don't know enough about
it to do it yet you can pay more
attention with details in this room oh I
thought I had to wait for more
information also you don't have you I
don't have my lighter
all right so I've thought this through I
don't know I never do you say that it's
all been it's all part of the plan dude
the master plan why are you going into
the shower cream and it's not the shark
room don't you do that there's some I
killed those sharks yeah you're
electrocuted the boss you know anything
I I did such a good job you're just like
jealous all right so there's stuff in
there so I don't need any of this stuff
I'm gonna put all of it away I'm gonna
put this so the weight I'm gonna examine
that book
can I open it alright interesting
I you think it's a something more mm-hmm
I can't open it can I doesn't appear to
be the case cuz like typically with
books you can open bandage with blood
all right it's a dumb name yeah it is
dumb i proofs finest work I can zoom in
I don't think that's gonna help me all
right well I don't know that doesn't
help me um oh I need my lighter so I'll
do that right now
I also ditched that one shotgun round
for now you can get rid of it later the
space is more important you think yeah
I'm fine with this discussion um yum yum
yum yum yum yum lighter lighter lighter
I wonder if I need fuel now it's an oil
lamp that oil is the fuel that makes
sense okay I didn't mean that like a
passive-aggressive dick way I just keep
thinking out loud but also cuz that
happen to you a lot where you giving
someone in solid advice or you
compliment me all the time there's a
sarcastic edge to it I don't I just
think it's a my ghost job in that review
it's like it's simple is like a nice
shirt I said that - Robbie their day and
told me go [ __ ] myself and I think it's
because I like just sound like it like
I'm yeah that's what we need that's why
you don't want me to kill them and
that's why you don't do you sarcastic no
that's not Iraq Ned will come at you
funny thing is in Latin Iraq no means
snake no
that's true all right so let's let's be
pragmatic about this is that the right
word for this situation so let's be
pregnant about this be pregnant about
this I got three lamps two spines and
two spiders are you sure oh don't you go
behind that bar see what's up I don't
think I can I can't can I I just light
one and see what happens can it's not
gonna kill you or anything I could like
like the red one because I have a red
book it's about that's about as far as
this puzzles got me you know that's
about as far as I've gone with it I got
a red book called bandage with blood and
it won't let me open it review Oh what
if like Jill just refuses to open it but
she opens it a name like the puzzles
spelled out right now okay it's green
orange yellow I'd like to I'd like to
light the red lamp I want to kill that
spider it's this is getting ridiculous
there's no reason for me to be this
upset all the time
okay I'm he's in my way
shut up thirsty station
I changed my mind
there's one over here as well I think no
there's the other one there's not he's
just drinking wine he's drinking all
that vintage wine all right so I lit one
okay
oh you mean this eyeball yeah so I could
write it down yellow suit
it's an eyeball with I'll write it on my
phone three eyelashes and one's thinking
Ellen under eyelash three eyelashes but
there's an under eyelash mm-hmm okay
three our red is three eyelashes I'll
write it down just in case we
technically it's four if you do that
under one sharpie his abdomen is pulsing
I'm shooting it
[ __ ] you yeah
I hope you like bullets oh let the
beetle listen to the rest of you spy
it's not [ __ ] around anymore you
previa enemy in this game spied Sam
Speights
char's I'm a busy person what's green
wow the Sharpie is strong smelling
feeling good getting eye that one is
none okay it's also it's like a cat I'm
more of a cat eye but more like an
Egyptian I'm wavelength of you we don't
know each other words I think he's
playing pool
you should join him oh right I forgot to
light it man can you smell this a
sharpie this is strong are you doing hi
that one has two eyelashes and it looks
like a normal line okay and it's orange
okay okay so and then there's these
billiard balls should you write these
down it's two three six
well yeah hold on well go back oh you
want to write down the colors so what
about the the color and the numbers is
that important like blue two three red
two and four are not important because
they don't correspond with an oil lamp
the colors right so this is the order
one orange
okay two eyelash thing no eyelash three
eyelashes right here let me look at the
sheets that we've made
that's my awful handwriting I never
progressed past third grade in terms of
calligraphy Oh calligraphy the study of
color that's what we're doing right now
why I know that's not what is why is
orange one because the first I mean five
looks yellow there but it should be it's
just the first one in the sequence
they're placed so orange green red not
mean the orange here it looks yellow it
should be so like the nine if there's
yellow right five is orange on a
billiard table but that's just going
from left to right right that's the
order of how things go
what's your reading like Japanese
alright so I have an order and I have
eyes and I have colors but does that
mean I should like unlike them and
relight them that doesn't sound right
that sounds like something I'm supposed
to do somewhere else yeah right I think
now I have a puzzle it's just you have
the order now I have information the
you look at it it looks like um looks
like that's his mouth we had this
discussion in the office how much money
would it take you to eat a tarantula
live it has to be a lot because I really
I think I have a weird thing with
spiders
well translates to they're furry and
they like it has to be like you can't
you can't kill it and then eat it you
have to kill it as you're eating it yeah
I didn't do it this gallery in the bee
room right yeah um sorry I can't like
pull off his legs one by one
correct I mean you could I don't think
that would kill it just hurt it uh you
know a hundred thousand is that enough
no really I don't know I really have a
problem with buyers its spiders don't
bother me I really don't like them okay
run not the basil watch The Wicker Man
go back Nicolas Cage hey running through
that field is he here yeah I didn't
remember actually way before you go in
go down this hallway to the left why cuz
just before it's I'm trying to save you
time oh [ __ ] back sorry wrong way back
the other way I don't want to look in
here No - what the [ __ ] oh that camera
is super weird nevermind I'm sorry yeah
you're the word stop making me hang on
these bees the baby's not the baby's
okay
how to cha cha cha cha all right cool
I mean I believe there's bees can I
shoot bees no I don't think actually
I've never tried
I would prioritize ah the bees right now
well try that three-door actually no try
this the hallway there's a hallway right
there - what yeah bees prey
oh man shark or something he's so
swollen and yes he's holding B spray
it's caulk insecticide spray yeah I
thought I was gonna okay don't go down
there
look at his eyes ooh Oh gross Oh Anakin
all right yeah so use you try
I feel like it isn't necessary because
now I'm covered go to the source it's
like a fire stick that is the source I'm
looking at the stores it's not it's not
like always sniper rifle insecticide gun
can we go the hallway that's what you
want that's what this is all about
that's what the be fun bees do not want
insecticide
what if has a joke there wasn't
insecticide there's like the t-virus
who's made the bees quadrupedal like ma
champ and just came at you what if like
all of these bugs ah sorry I panicked
sorry sorry I panicked
wait did you not use it no I forgot
protect the Queen that one dick just son
you still you did like it should be gone
soon I don't know why this maybe it
takes a double spray good sick oh crap
I'm on caution you thinking of that my
head you'll be fine
oh no I'm not ready for that the locking
mechanism I don't even know how to use
it you didn't even try should I try
first
there was a red herb near the bees nest
I would probably there's two red herb
there's one by the double door here do
those rays a thingy I'm gonna there
might be a point coming up but I'm gonna
try to save you time but yeah I died so
badly look girls room for that right now
I mean you do but I mean can I just eat
it don't don't look you're mad at me
sorry that's alright alright
oh look at that shot yeah that's good
all right that's really good locked up
look at em cab that [ __ ] oh it's cheap
boom they're amazing though yeah he
looks like an elf
if Galadriel got stung in the cheeks
examine that key okay
I'm sorry if I'm giving you too much
dance to try to rush me along okay so
all right I'm gonna try to I'm gonna try
to open the store okay do you do
actually okay actually
so I screwed up right well we're fine
but it's not the order the football is
the actual balls so the balls that red
was three lashes was red which is a
three no that's right Green is six
orange is five so sorry I feel like
you're going too far for me here hold on
so the three no no no I want to do it on
my own I want to process this in my
brain so I have like
so it's not the number in which the
balls were ordered it's the number
that's on the ball yeah which is these
right and the colors are significant
alright so the number that was on the
ball was three that was so three out
eyelashes that's number one
Green was two eyelashes
no well Green was the cat eye and that's
six in orange no I [ __ ] up how do I
end ears back out you can also like this
is just to say time you can actually you
have to actually click on the the eye
buttons those are buttons those aren't
just indicators oh oh
so the red and so flashy so that's it
mm-hmm yellow oh that's cool though
because think so this is re right now
what's happening is re it's just only
pushing further the fact that this is
yellow which I think was hard to
understand yeah but you really
technically supposed to be orange but
this is a weird orange now they're color
choices are weird sweet shy going here
oh [ __ ] took with oh my god you asked
that did you go in here you're so fun
you have a green herb I'm just kidding
you're fine kidding well now we have to
watch this door animation because you
may panic I just really like this this
is Brenda
alright let's go
a red herb fills me one health right I
hear it know if it doesn't what is that
cockroaches I think the puzzle coming up
hold on a second actually
no I'm serious it's time back out you
want to get rid of that key you need all
the spaces you do you can get for this
room no you mean unlock the third door
yeah
but I want to know what's in this room
there isn't anything ID must be
cockroaches it's a horrible noise you
owe me I will I'm on lower health should
I just eat that herb awesome go back go
to just use the key on door three to get
rid of it you want to go in there too
I'm going in okay either you can get rid
of another item I'm going in okay this
is the same room or something should not
take this yet I would hold off yeah
check the rest of the room out there's a
mirror there's never a good mirrors are
never good but this is a safe room so
there's nothing nothing bad could happen
in here
oh mama yes I want this book organic
chemistry lab experiment the
similarities in the cellular
characteristics of the rapidly growing
plant infected by the tyrant virus have
been reported in previous papers however
while repeating these experiments an
interesting new fact became clear this
is important by the way yeah I know that
is your you have a pen and paper out I'm
sorry
we learned that a chemical in the UMB
family um be number 20 contained a
compound that is toxic to the cells of
the plant
so um B number twenty is toxic or
something we have given um B number
twenty a new name V jolt
that's stupid name the jolt sounds like
a really sexual energy drink oh but
y'all took four women and peppiness four
men no BP Joel [ __ ] you're right I
[ __ ] up the name convention put jolt
thing that you'd assume it's for men
when it says penis and hit women can
take it to won't hurt you feel quite
nice if calculations proved correct the
jolt
is applied directly to the root of the
plant the entire plant should be dead
within five seconds
you know what plant they're talking
about um strangled you and [ __ ] yeah I
remember I was down in the lab he did
strangle me
yeah he strangled you twice the vigil
can be made by simply mixing the VP and
um B chemicals in a specific ratio
however extra care must be taken when
handling these um B chemicals they have
been known to generate toxic gas if
mishandled okay so I'll die if I do this
wrong
the characteristics of each um B
chemical are as follows all right write
it on your arm
sure number three is red yellow six is
yellow that I like that naming
convention number seven is green number
ten is orange seventeen is blue and the
jolt is dark brown okay but it didn't
tell me how to order them I go back they
have to mix in a specific ratio yeah
what's the ratio yeah we'll figure it
out we got it okay enough information
Oh what the [ __ ] is that giant plant is
culture he's crushing the wall a swarm
of angry moths surrounds it like I give
a [ __ ] about moths from what I've seen I
don't care how angry they are what are
they gonna do about it nothing losers
should I save no I wouldn't know if you
need you right now unless you royally
[ __ ] up the chemicals thank you bye
I mean you just never know all right so
I got a red book I got a lighter
I got a plant and I got some gun and
ammo and I'm on caution should I eat
this herb I'd like to know I don't know
don't do that you're you're wasting red
herbs if you use it like that go into
this room too right oh the bathroom yes
all right I'm trying to work through
this thing to save time like in using
background knowledge Oh another tub that
always works draining those right
umbrella core
mm-hmm this one's just not tense at all
there's something in the bathtub with
the a dagur I don't think you're so J
thank you
tap the washbasin the tap for the waters
magazine and this plants all over can I
use the toilet no all right that's it
this place is clean so I'd like to go
back to the chemical plant your left oh
no I don't want it oh wait wait hon you
can go there's something in your Vittori
you can get rid of right now if you want
well I don't have a thing in here are
you talking about there's something in
your inventory right now that you can
get rid of in this room like I can use
this book or something yeah I could
probably put it back yes that makes
sense
reorder the books oh yeah it makes the
naked lady naked lady naked lady naked
lady they're all over this residence
these guys were perverts feet wait oh I
have to do it with that way I hate that
but you know what I'm talking about what
I like swap them this is like a lame way
to do it you're talking about it's just
like it takes a long time to do it this
way I did it
she's a naked lady now okay wait to hold
go through there this is just for the
purposes of I don't want to beautiful
die why don't I just save okay
yeah save then try it out I am I'm gonna
do that okay they never make it out of
here this is my game and I'm gonna play
it my way and I'm gonna go into the
bathroom we're gonna die of impatience
very real thing that I that I've
experienced yes
o3 I didn't want you to take those no
you cook I thought it was just one I
didn't know
I didn't know I got it I'll save three
times and get rid of them now
why does eat the Red Planet I don't care
if I'm not utilizing it properly you can
eat it if you want I'm gonna let you
learn from your mistakes though I have
so many plans you're fine you don't need
to get rid of anything for a minute or
now just don't go oh okay you can go
through that door that looks like an
astronaut something you shouldn't go out
through this door
hmm place looks like it's covered in
spiders okay I'm dying yeah but you're
not moving which is interesting to me
because you just got like poison in here
okay there's a plan okay come on caution
Oh
Oh Elvis getting attacks in here what
are these plant you're out just back
here oh yeah um yeah you I would say
just do the chemistry puzzle okay yeah
did I go into zero double O 3 yet I
think I did okay so investigate this
room a little farther before you like
before I begin chemistry yeah I mean you
need those containers what I need is an
order okay here we go I'll write this
down for you as well
there's not a lot of space but I'll
write down ignore this stuff I kind of
I'm doing that from memory I just wanna
make sure I'm not [ __ ] up all right
one plus three equals four nice I know
all these things four plus six equals
ten one plus six equals seven mmm ten
plus seven equals 17 and 17 plus three
equals 20 okay I promise you though
you're not just obviously they're
important I know they are because excuse
me that the one that I want the plant
killed
that's strong it's called NC 20 mic off
you know the sharpie quit sniffing the
Sharpie okay I want I want vajay 20
right yes you do so I need to make 17
and 3 yeah but there is no three maybe
there's three um be number three okay so
I need to make 17 so here's what I'm
trying over they tell you this one point
okay yeah exhale first you need this
containers to make 17
all right I know I'm doing the math in
my head I need to make a one plus six I
don't think it's gonna make complete
sense until you see and I need to make a
four plus six
yeah but to make a four plus six I need
to make a one plus three mm-hmm so I
need okay I got it
oh it's all in there now I got it I need
your help I'm gonna die cool yeah these
are pretty much just your tools that you
need for the puzzle yeah no okay how
much the audence you want here like okay
I'm you need I need it no move okay keep
in mind if you like [ __ ] anything up
you're gonna die or it's gonna hurt you
really badly so I'm just saying get two
more containers so you could turn oh
don't get two containers I don't I know
so do it one of the pie instead of
getting all the containers and then
mixing them get to mix what you need
right so I need three don't I well you
need at least one more to make smell
okay sorry I know okay I have this one
that's three and what's this one six
read it one more time mm-hmm so I need
one where's my one that's question yeah
that is the question right okay I don't
know what to do with water is water 100
maybe you're onto something I could be
it what's so anticlimactic that you say
yes well I I don't know I think so
you'd think in all their [ __ ] books
and the fact that they wrote down basic
math on the wall that they would have
put water equals one somewhere in this
goddamn place mm-hmm you would think so
you would think that I don't see
anything else you should think that oh
you're saying that they totally wrote it
down somewhere
no they didn't I don't see anything
there's nothing else you're you're
you've got it I just need to do the math
and pick up another container to make
some I can do it yeah girl okay
my one piece of advice you say enough to
go back to save room don't pick up
another container until you do the first
mixed cuz right because I don't want a
bunch of [ __ ] so you got water in
one three so the first clue was one plus
three is four yeah it wasn't a clue it
was math well the first thing you need
to do yeah nice
okay so I got for now and also so you
got four yeah wait oh let me let me do
it okay yeah you got it I'm a math whiz
you just if I'm making a real big [ __ ]
just be like haha alright so four plus
six equals 10 so I'll just add it with
six that makes sense that makes total
sense now I got 10 but I need to make so
you just did 4 plus 6 equals 10 right so
now I need to make a 7 mm-hmm
okay so I need to actually start not
again I need to like wait I do I need to
start from scratch
well not from I know you're saying you
just need to get pick up another
container right or do you yeah yeah you
do I do cuz if you mix if you mix the
purple with how does it know what to
butch container to put it in it's just
whatever you have empty you I don't
think it's gonna automatically come oh
it doesn't automatically combine it will
you can only combine them in you
inventory not when you're picking them
up got it alright so I'm just doing the
same thing that I just did but when I
get to 6 stop you're trying to make 7 so
you can add it great so I need to make 1
plus 3 2 no 1 plus 6 it's more I think
you're overcomplicating it those
directions are much more literal than
your
making them out to be right I do need a
container to make water though to add
water no so I'm gonna take a container
correct cha-cha and then six and then
combine that makes seven and now I can
combine ten and seven to make seventeen
mm-hmm I've made seventeen so remember
the book earlier said 17 is blue so
you're on the right track and it says 17
right there also I think it clearly
tells me you try to reassure you all
right I've reassured um so I want to
make 20 right or something mm-hmm all
right so I just I just add this one this
part is crucial I just add them yeah go
ahead and try and see what happens I
will the math it's on the wall written
crudely nice background there you go
good job I made Virgil I oddly enjoy
that puzzle every time I do it it's nice
to do math it's not really math it's
like basic math but it's so fun all
right
so can I smash these on the floor I'm
fairly certain if you try to leave the
room and others said you want to discard
these except for the jolt you smashed
the vigil on the floor on your way a
hunt and have a what I think you can
just drop them I don't think you could
just drop anything from the inventory
maybe I'll ask right here
I don't want these
let's put him in your say box I guess
well then I had to go all the way to a
save box I want to before I kill that
thing I would like to heal up all I have
is red plant though I would say go back
to your save box because you're all
right so the one clue that I think you
might have overlooked in the whole color
thing yeah yeah the base of the plant
where's the base you did see it in last
episode I just think you were too
stressed out to remember it also I need
to remember we're the save boxes or the
item box alright so I got to go through
B alley so I'm taking a left
what's B alley Oh B alley is this how
you're like like the letter B this is
where this is where the bees were yeah
it's not that complicated okay I'm not
gonna help you with anything anywhere in
this whole entire goddamn series watch
you die I'm gonna enjoy doing it I'm
gonna roll beers next time close one cil
mmm I don't need you next episode I'm
just gonna stay here watch no okay
should we good [ __ ] things are gonna get
heated next step next an epic n dude
nobody says that I said every penny
there are bees oh I thought you were
saying that because of the news of them
going like up in yeah price like $500
evening I don't want these [ __ ]
models
should I save just because I did all
that math and I don't want to redo it
probably not worth it is it
no all right well I'm still gonna put
these back because I don't need them
right now bring to the J I'm gonna keep
the VJ and I'm gonna take an herb and
I'm gonna use it and then I'm gonna take
another herb for me like one for now one
for later basically well now that you
have should I do some combining well
yeah I think I read in the green and
there's combined those cuz you're on
yellow so if you get hit once more you
can just use a red and a green but I
wouldn't bring two greens well I don't
like getting hit even at all like I'd
rather have more than not enough
do you I mean now I got some drugs I got
my the jolts I've got some ammo I'm not
saving which makes me very nervous so
you did see the base of the plant I mean
I just feel better the obvious thing I
could tell you is that roots are usually
you have to go down to get to them what
a hint feel like this is one of those
likes the last episode record is like a
week ago yeah this game's better if you
just do them close together but so wait
it shows on the map right now you can
see the stairs
no so the stairs are there the
billiard-room stairs here are that the
plant 42 boss room so oh you mean this
yeah and that looks like it goes
downstairs mm-hmm based on the arrow
although it's pointing up but yes you're
right
alright so I gotta go to be Ali and then
I take the second door which I don't
remember what was in there ah
she's scaring me now how does it feel
nice but that's probably just the video
talking Jill coming to a store near you
the jolt get some pep in your step
oh man are you unpopular super
inappropriate parties for jolt spice
things up where it matters mm-hmm
treading dangerous water boom there you
go door to double O to double O to yes
this sounds good where am I
wait a minute save room it's just the
noise you're confusing save room music
with just creepy music they are similar
the the safe room music has a harp it's
my play station like many music as well
no I didn't I don't I can't predict when
crimson heads are gonna come back I
gotta kill him yeah but you know the
shotgun I would say Josh I got lots of
bullets
Shoom Shoom
he's a crimson head though he's gonna
[ __ ] you up you need to knock back you
got a dagger never might you'd be find
the dagger dad dad I got this Oh yep
ladder
wait what's the ladder [ __ ] I'm
freaking out I'm panicking I'm sorry
he so if he swipes you're not gonna be
able use a dagger if he tries it you
should let him grab you where did he get
those meaty claws he's a crimson head
don't play by the rules
forget I remember you killing a zombie
in there but I didn't consider the
crimson head thing I panicked mm-hmm he
didn't grab me he was trying to I would
say should I try again
yeah but if he hits you once obviously
use that red and green I will say he is
your biggest he is your last threat for
a while
hate this mm-hmm [ __ ] this guy don't
swipe me well that was way simpler than
weed there was a lot of panic about that
yes sure no he's dead jail is like I
don't know what you guys are worried
about I aimed at his face and I shot him
alright so go down here mm-hmm
that was perfect because we could not
see anything past that bed I don't need
to explain it we know I had scared us
you see it was scary because you thought
he was gonna kill you okay I remember
this part
oh that's good yeah this is that door
that was locked in the other side
originally but I opened it right so use
it it's there it's a shortcut
yeah yeah the nice-sounding go -
rattling - wd-40 you're really into that
door noises comin in this game
this place looks like a garbage dump did
you need to say garbage dump other kind
of dumps are there oh I know
since I got poop dump place looks like a
CC house way off [ __ ] wait I actually
kind of that shortcut wasn't necessary
wait oh that's where the shark is but
he's dead oh I was totally wrong that
shortcut was not a shortcut yeah you
know where you are check on here no just
the coot no that's where the giant shark
was but I guess why I just go through
here and then up through the control
room yeah my bed you've no idea the
blind leading the blind
I want you went too far down what you
said routes go down they do but not this
far
so upstairs sharky low kneeling no he
would never be called that okay in
chompers chompers trying to think of a
Kobe Bryant pun to round out the Lakers
with a sharp hi you fought shark eel
O'Neal and then you fought Cobra Bryant
up in the attic
it's been come on that was good it's
been such it's been a week and that
dude's alive yeah like that's not
accurate wait am I supposed to get am I
going Sharkey Llewelyn Cobra Bryant the
people watching will he'll respect that
because I came from that red area and
everything else is green where did you
bring me I don't think they're going
it'll jog remember when you going but
it's green I know it doesn't
no one says there's an item you need to
pick up oh I thought green but you were
done with the room it just means there's
no more I am to pick up Oh remember you
came in here yes I loved it I don't
really look like roots yeah it looks
like a bunch of jolts
melted it suck it yeah yeah cool
now that room is open upstairs it looks
like a control system but it's broken
that's it yep you killed the plant or at
least weakened it just felt a little
anticlimactic yeah you know we're going
now back to the plant room mm-hmm
what's the longest way it takes me to
get there oh boy am I excited cuz I know
dude the exact route if you're going
this way this way don't go this way
let's go back to the normal well there's
a shark there have you seen sharknado
any of them yes I saw the first one me
too
I think I tapered off after that but I
do watch the highlight you're a sensible
human being oh yeah so like every
sharknado they'll be like one ridiculous
kill and I typically will watch like
when something like that happens like a
shark
I don't know it's always the same but
like they'll be like a berated celebrity
who gets eaten or something oh come on
the wrong way oh [ __ ] the waters drained
you do need to go yeah sorry about that
oh man you asked for the longest way
around you I got it so wait does that
mean you were right the first time like
you actually had to do yes
the way you told me so I was right the
first time yeah just wrong this time you
just didn't realize that you were right
mhm so I gotta go in here yep go down
I'm gonna go back up yeah that's dumb go
down the stairs then go back up some
stairs good for her
yeah she's gonna be ripped after this
game ends
it's got a good head on her doors
let it fill your ear space yeah station
tubes you ever popped in here drum no
that sounds awful ruptured meant the
same one twice I mean my ears have
popped is that what you mean
no like happens all the time on
airplanes I'm like that was inconvenient
no that's totally different
I've ruptured the same here okay there
my mind off that story you ruptured it
twice the same one he Oldman was it from
someone yelling at you no a lacrosse
ball someone took a shot there's a vent
right over here so you can hear and it
hit that and the sound from it hitting
my helmet ruptured it and then it healed
and then sounds awful like I was firing
a weapon actually in a ruptured again
yeah just get his weekend usually a gun
wouldn't do that but you saw were
earplugs and I just don't think I was
yeah come up that sounds like you didn't
think his negligence really yeah it
sounds like it was your fault well the
first time no cuz I didn't with a
lacrosse ball in my own head but could
have worn your plugs when I was firing a
gun mm-hmm
all right my gun I would laugh if that
crimson head and just shut up he's dead
the headless crimson head is still alive
Cobra Brian oh man I'm not I'm not
letting go until you give me the praise
that those cons deserve so although I
don't think yarn is a Cobra so I wanted
to take a left and go through there
mm-hmm
back to the gallery through the Galleria
gallery
I got you like what your overarching
what you're trying to get right now is
in the entire game I thought I was
trying to like leave or something well I
mean yeah I guess escape would be nice
so wait is it not dead cuz if it no cuz
I'm on caution you'll find out and I
haven't saved in a really long time
that's right get back up there you want
some more of a jolt no yes what the hell
is this thing don't ask questions just
learn it very
lucky he had that yeah thank God for
Barry yeah good thing you still have to
fight the planet right now and you only
have a hand got him oh shut up
thought it was finished yeah that was
close was thanks again
don't mention it but what was that what
the hell's going on in this place we say
that like every time I see them yeah we
get it Barry you don't know what's going
on this is the perfect time to tell you
I'm in love with you that's that's how I
tell people pulls out some Pujols site
Oh mansion key to the keymaster
what is this [ __ ] Kingdom Hearts
that's Keyblade master in there one if
you want the gate keeper I was I guess
there's nothing else in here it's also
probably good time down in the episode
once you examine the key very keep
staring at me man Oh helmet yeah it's
the last set of doors need to open yeah
I'm getting there
cool probably signed it ultimate rock
coming right now if you want Barry I
love you something about that mansion
still bothers me something but I think
I'll stay here put my finger giant snake
or split up again investigation
reanimated corpses are the general
layout of this house it's probably good
place - all right we did it you're done
with the residence and I have a key you
can go back to the Mansi on I'm going
things about to get spooky on the next
episode the final episode we finished
the game huh sure
thank you guys for watching and don't
forget to Like and subscribe so we can
keep doing this kind of stuff it's fun
thanks a lot